And you might disagree.
For the sake of principle component analysis actually it turns out to be
two dimensional.
Even though there's clearly a one dimensional structure underneath this
data that you could draw.
It seems pretty clear that whatever you have to do to the coordinate system
twists it in some sort of a non-linear way.
And PCA in particular specializes on just shifts and
rotation for the coordinate system.
And you can't possibly come up with a coordinate system that is just shifted and
only rotated from the original one to obtain one-dimensionality.
So, as a result, two is the answer I wanted and it was a trick question.
It was certainly a little unfair.
Because the best you can possibly do is put a coordinate system like this and
like this, where there's still significant variation in the y-dimension,
in the data points.
Way too much for my taste to call it one-dimensional.